what a great what a great audience for
Monday uh doesn't even feel like a
Monday to me all right so
thank you so do you hear what China did
yeah they cloned super cows
Chinese scientists say they've cloned
three calves that once grown will be
capable of producing 50 percent more
milk than the average American cow
so they're putting our cows out to
pasture like voters did to Hillary
that is a reach but I approve
by the way I believe we have a picture
of this new super cows
[Applause]
that's off to a good start
okay enough of that let's talk about
giant balloons all right
no
not those I mean the Chinese
surveillance balloon shot down up the
coast of South Carolina China should
have said there was a boy inside
that's what I would have done then I
would have shot it down
because I'm a bad man anyway there was
lots of speculation over the balloon
sudden appearance rumor has it Joe
insisted that it was just a full moon
maybe it came from Hunter's birthday
party from last Saturday
you know he loves his balloons you know
normally if they're full of cocaine and
shoved up a drug mule's ass but still
you know hunter in the balloon have a
lot in common they're both paid for by
China and highest
laughs
the foreign Chinese foreign Ministry
says it was civilian weather balloon
that's straight off course and entered
U.S airspace by accident and like most
illegal border crossers it just decided
to stick around but that excuse is as
believable as kill Mead's Alibi when
Fox's Christmas tree was torched
yeah blame it on the homeless guy
China called our response an
overreaction but then issued a threat of
further actions in response possibly in
the form of streamers cake and confetti
because it was a balloon audience
yeah there you go
sometimes you gotta Goose them
but what a journey the balloon had right
it got to see more States than Forrest
Gump on a jog and the public got a good
look at it too videos were all over
social media people filming it from
their backyards it was the best thing to
happen in Montana since Custer's Last
Stand
it was the only thing to happen in
Montana since Custer's Last Stand and
perhaps it was the public who forced
this Administration to get off their fat
lazy asses and do something about this
if people weren't documenting it would
the White House have even acted at all
or would they let it flow to Europe
where it would end up dating a woman
with armpit hair
[Laughter]
no one deserves that not even a balloon
filled with explosives
the White House says Biden was first
briefed on Tuesday three days after it
entered the U.S air defense Zone and
worse the response was softer than Mike
lindell's Giza dream sheets
have you tried them
have you tried them really
the Pentagon says the balloon wasn't a
threat but admitted it could be
maneuverable which is more than we can
say about Joe
so is this really a big deal maybe maybe
not I don't know that's what I hate
about these stories suddenly Everyone's
an expert on whatever it is we're
talking about and I don't know
so I'll refer you to retired army
General John Ferrari he says the flight
might have been to gauge America's
ability to detect incoming threats and
to find holes in our air defense warning
system so the balloon was up and I mean
really up to no good
which brings us back to this
[Laughter]
yeah
the trans teacher with a massive
knockers
it was another case where someone was up
to no good but people were too scared to
call it out for fear of being labeled as
bigoted
and also popping those breasts would
have set the teacher gusting all the way
to China
and with China we were also too scared
to act quickly for fear of offense
and let's not forget the Kung Fu flu
right it's been three years that we
still have no answer from China on its
Origins because questioning such things
could be seen as racist and it was if
only if it came if only it came from
Norway or Sweden or perhaps the Osmond
family
here's the bottom line I linked this
balloon story to the Ontario trans
teacher with giant boobs so for those
playing the Gutfeld drinking game at
home you have to take two shots now and
from two giant cups
thank God Emily's here no one would
laugh
so from fentanyl to tick tock we've got
major issues with China and now just let
a spy balloon casually Cruise right over
us like it was bringing Dorothy back to
Kansas
if it were me I would have steered the
damn thing into the Space Needle
because what's the point of having a
space needle except to poke holes in
space balloons I mean I bet the needle
was just sitting there the whole time
thinking guys I'm right here
never gonna get this opportunity again
in the meantime I guess we can just take
comfort in the fact that it took a
balloon to remind us that we all share
something in common we hate when
strangers get into our
and that the bigger problem for us is
this conflict as sport China unleashes a
spy balloon and it should unite every
one of us across the country all
pointing upward we should be pointing
fingers at China and not at each other
but with immediates who can blame the
other party first but you know who I
blame for that
Joe Biden
yeah I'm a hypocrite but I know I am and
Joe was elected based on unifying but
instead cleaned us like a head of
lettuce on Iron Chef
but hopefully the next wind bag we get
rid of will be him
[Applause]
yes you may recognize him from the last
time you Googled non-threatening white
guy co-host of the big money show Brian
brinberg
she was the only lawyer whose clients
asked her to remain silent outnumbered
co-host Emily compagno
you know critics said we'd never be able
to book timeout Magazine's joke of the
Year winner 2009
but here we are
westernrazor.com owner David Angelo
and finally she's like a pretzel Twisted
salty and better when smothered in hot
mustard Fox News contributor cactive
so David why the Hat what's on your head
well you know Greg I've come on the show
several times and I'm always pumping the
Western razor company and I figure you
know what I don't need to keep saying it
let's just let's just put it up here get
it out of the way and then we can get
down to business it's not doing very
well is it yeah you know
I'm living in the YMCA and uh
but you know what we're talking about
balloons here you make razors you must
have your own you could have probably
solved this problem much faster than our
daughter and president well you know I
think uh our operation is part of the
reason why they sent that over here
really made in America razors come on
we're threatening in the entire industry
they're a little worried yeah that's
what I'm thinking but you know the
weirdest thing about this is like all
you had to do is send a balloon over to
spy yeah like why did we make you two's
why did we do as we made the fastest
plane in history to fly over Russia
Garrett Francis Gary Powers you know yes
this whole thing all we had to do is go
to Party City yep
love one over Leningrad it's true why
did we work so hard where's my money
well that's the thing it's like we got
cheated I it's a huge balloon too I
would have loved I love big balloons
don't you Emily big balloons are fun and
they've used this fund for evil I hate
China for what they've done to our
balloons what do you think they've
ruined every birthday party from now yes
what do you think about the public going
up watching it and then the media
turning it into the uh some kind of
blame game what do you make of this yeah
I think well I think that the
administration is trying to turn this
into a success story for President Biden
when it's anything but because what we
do know so it entered our airspace three
days later he was informed was that
because he wasn't trusted with the
information is it because he doesn't
have the respect of our defense and
intelligence communities I'm not sure
but then he said he told them to shoot
it down right away which either they
ignored or had a better plan either way
his fridge agility is on Full display
here and first of all I miss secretary
Pompeo and president Trump so much
because under their watch this would not
have happened the instant something from
the CCP entered our airspace violated
international law and then our Sovereign
airspace it would have been shot down
over the Pacific not the Atlantic so the
fact that he now Pats himself on the
back and says this is a success after
it's collected who knows what
um you know intelligence files of
Intelligence on on the entire
continental U.S there's nothing
successful about it and the Chinese must
have known we would shoot it down which
means it was worth it whatever modicum
up to a huge amount of surveillance that
they got during that Journey was worth
it to them which means it was getting a
whole hot a whole hell of a lot more
than we expected I also think that it
provides this sort of visual
representation of what China's been
doing for us for years which is
infiltrating our Sovereign Nation at any
point from cyber security to physical
bases our education system
lawn furniture there you go now we just
have the visual representation for it so
I hope that we keep our fingers in the
sky the middle one oh wow
[Laughter]
she is um she is filthy uh Brian welcome
to the show this is your friend thank
you I'm so glad it's been a long time
coming but you know I've heard good
things I'm glad you could do the balloon
thing 20 times when I came too that's
really great kids at home will love that
oh yeah that's good what do you uh do
you think this could have been handled
better well there's so many excuses
being made and most of them are really
bad but the worst one is that there's no
room in Montana to take this down like
Montana is the Atlantic Ocean of States
okay if you can take a balloon down you
can do it there the Biden family must
have never taken a road trip in Montana
to believe that you couldn't do it but
before that it was in Alaska this thing
was in the illusion an Islands a Chinese
spy balloon and they knew about it there
for two days yeah and they didn't do
anything of all the excuses they've made
the worst one is that they couldn't have
acted preemptively they could have and
as a result China got who knows what
kind of intelligence from this they saw
how attractive our mule or our moose are
how do you say plural of moose Miss yeah
really
it's not he had me there for a minute
there
he did but there is an argument
cat that if we were to shoot them down
what if it was filled with like covered
spores or something like that or it was
filled with something that if you
detonated would explode and then kill
everybody but then in Alaska and Montana
that's 12 people oh God
I'm kidding I love those people
sometimes say I love them too much I
have some great customers in Montana
[Music]
I look I'm not I'm not a spy balloon
expert
[Laughter]
but I should have been yes
because I could have been in these
meetings when they were like designing
this thing I could have been like hey
guys it's kind of big
[Laughter]
not very sneaky no it isn't at all it's
not sneaky at all like I didn't know
what a spy balloon looked like but now
that I do I mean yeah
nothing else looks like that why does
that have to be so big I would think it
would be you'd have to make it smaller
someone in the meeting somewhere should
have said hey
we should make it maybe make it more
smaller yeah exactly
I mean like when you wear a wire they
don't put like lights in it yeah that's
true that's true oh I we're gonna see it
but I you know again not an expert but
that is a huge missed opportunity on my
part yeah that's true you should be
thinking your career choices during this
story it's raised definitely more
questions than it's answered right hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else